welcome back
Welcome back everyone toss the coin to your
witcher netflix just dropped the witcher season 2
trailer there's a whole bunch of easter eggs so of
course we'll break it all down they also released
a trailer for the witcher movie that's right they
made a witcher movie because it plays into what's
happening during the events of the witcher season
2. if you're new to the channel i'll be doing
videos for season 2 for the witcher movie for
all this stuff so be sure to subscribe to get
everything but what i'll do is i'll talk mostly
about the season 2 footage during this and the
stuff that they discussed about season 2 and then
i'll sort of work in the witcher movie trailer
later in the video because it's kind of a separate
thing but it's important for what happens during
season two and big reminder season two episodes
are coming december 17th which is around the same
time that season one premiered a couple years
ago it's been 84 years since season 1 premiered
it seems like it's been 84 years the witcher movie
is coming august 23rd or at the end of august so
we're actually gonna get the movie before we get
season two and that'll be important because of
how the movie helped set up what happens during
season two i'll cover that when we get to that
part of the video because it's all about Kaer
Morhen what's happening there but during the
trailer we get a first look at pretty much all
the major storylines in all the major characters
almost everything not quite everybody but enough
of it there's still a couple big surprises i think
they're holding back on for season two and we're
really only moving into blood of elves story right
now if you're going to read along the novels
you have plenty of time if you want to read
the witcher books for the most part they're doing
about one novel a little bit more than one novel
per each season so that's where we're gonna
get like four or five seasons bare minimum of
the witcher but the official synopsis for season
two reads convinced yennefer's life was lost at
the battle of sadden hill geralt of rivia brings
princess cirilla to the safest place he knows his
childhood home of Kaer Morhen while the continents
kings elves humans and demons strive for supremacy
outside its walls he must protect the girl from
something far more dangerous the mysterious power
she possesses inside so for the most part all
the trailer voice over dialogue series voice over
geralt's voice over even vesamir's voiceover
we actually get our first look at vesemir
all deals with what's changing and how ciri
is at the center of all that her elder blood
ethylene's prophecy about the white frost also the
changing political landscape the changing map of
the continent itself because that's also going on
in the background too but you'll notice that it's
winter when this is happening so then going back
to the keep coincides with the annual tradition
of witchers returning to their home castles the
schools that they come from for rest in recovery
which for geralt is the school of the wolf there
are many other schools of witchers across the
continent maybe someday we'll see some of the
others maybe in the spin-offs because they're
already doing a witcher prequel series witcher
blood origin we didn't really get a trailer for
that during this big witcher convention but it
is happening you can see that they're plotting
out a witcher cinematic universe on netflix so
there's going to be a lot of other spin-off stuff
happening outside of henry cavill's geralt in ciri
but most of series dialogue narrated the trailer
is about her being afraid of her power wanting
to learn more about it and kind of wondering if
geralt is someone that she can trust for real like
are you just gonna bolt the first sign of trouble
like what's all this talk about me being your
destiny about does that actually mean something or
do i mean something more to you then geralt trying
to calm her down a little bit basically telling
her that he's going to help her try to learn
more about her power and let her know that he's
going to be watching over her protecting her papa
bless geralt kind of becomes her surrogate father
yennefer kind of becomes her surrogate mother but
as you can see yennefer is nowhere to be found at
the beginning of season two because she does show
up at the end of the trailer like oh surprise i'm
not dead pretty much anybody that's ever heard of
the witcher or played any of the games knew that
she was alive it was just a question of how they
were going to reveal that so ciri undergoes all
the normal training witchers get including combat
training potions monster lore it's just that she
doesn't undergo the trial of the grasses so she's
kind of a witcher but kind of not in an official
capacity but the thing is ciri is so powerful on
her own she doesn't need the powers that geralt
and the other witchers gain through the trial the
grasses just to fight monsters she's already the
most powerful person on the planet when geralt
says the world is changing during the trailer you
see them sitting amidst all the snowfall of the
gates here they're on the new version of roach
if you're not a big witcher fan the funny thing
about roaches is that he has many different horses
he just calls all them roach so it only seems like
it's the same horse across the entire series but
what he means when he says the world is changing
is it's both a political statement like emperor
emhyr of nilfgaard which we actually see during
the trailer we see nilfgaard the capital city
the emperor is going around trying to unite the
entire continent slowly basically conquering all
the different areas making them submit to him so
the power structure of the continent is changing
rapidly you also notice the nilfgaardian armor
changed quite a bit during this so they get a boss
level upgrade to that nutsac looking armor from
season one that people complained about so much
but when geralt talks about the world changing
he's also talking about it in a cosmic sense
like a magical sense like the prophecy about the
elder blood the white frost slowly coming closer
slowly moving towards another conjunction of the
spheres which only happens every thousand years
or so and wally's talking about this you see
them walking amidst all these snowy landscapes
that's foreshadowing for the actual white frost
itself but that's sort of like end game for the
show so i have a feeling that even though they'll
talk about it she'll learn more about the prophecy
more about her elder blood you won't actually
see them pay off her trying to stop the white
frost till the very end of the show like whatever
the final episode of the series winds up being
but the whole idea is that pretty much every
main faction that you run into every main group
within the witcher series wants ciri in her
elder blood power for some reason but that's
one of the big reasons why it's so important
that geralt protect ciri there weren't really
any main villains in the world of the witcher
now there are people you could point to and say
okay these people are as close as you would get
to maine villains they're a lot of antagonists
like you have emperor emhyr vilgefortz eredin and
the wild tunt and a lot of lesser really terrible
people that geralt and ciri run into during their
adventures so it's one of those situations in the
world of the witcher where almost everybody is
terrible but then they finally make it to Kaer
Morhen the keep we get our first look we see
the new witcher characters from season two like
vesemir eskel lambert coen they're all there to
help train ciri geralt hands her a sword there's
a better picture of her training with lambert in
the yard too you also see geralt training with his
sword separately and if you played the games most
of the keep itself will look familiar it sounds
like they try to be pretty accurate to the way
the book describes the keep the video game changes
some things from the books but they also try to
be pretty accurate as well the show is mostly
following the books though so this is where we get
to the idea of the witcher movie the nightmare of
the wolf so it's an anime movie but it's going to
tell the story of young vesemir during the sacking
of kare marin explaining why the keat looks so
dilapidated in present-day why it's so broken down
in why they can't create any more new witchers why
they lost the ability to make the potions for the
trial the grasses that movie is coming at the end
of august so i'll try to do a big easter egg video
for that but as you can see it just sort of gives
you more context for what's happening during the
witcher season 2 because so much of the beginning
of the season especially will be spent at the keep
and it's one of the most important places one of
the most important locations in the world of the
witcher then you see ciri walking around the rooms
of the keep exploring she'll be much more of a pov
character during season two than she was during
season one so they'll show you a lot of the keep
as she's experiencing it for the first time and
learning about all the history of the witchers
here at the school of the wolf this is also really
cool easter egg here too her looking in the armory
at these witcher swords these are all just their
regular steel swords but they always carry two
one steal one silver one for people and one for
special monsters like vampires werewolves and the
like ciri touching them is nice foreshadowing for
her getting her own witcher sword which is named
zireal which is elder speech for swallow which
is also her true name issues that everyone she
knows just calls her ciri or cirilla like geralt
does during the trailer not that many people she
runs into actually know elder speech the footage
of geralt topped off with potions here if you look
at his eyes in the snowy courtyard is from the
events of episode one in the grain of truth story
at nevelen's mansion you can see that he's in the
middle of this fight with vereena the brooks in
her vampire form i've already done a couple videos
about this because they said they were going to do
this story from the books a while ago but it's
basically the witcher's version of a twisted
darker version of beauty and the beast novella
being played by tormund giantsbane from game of
thrones it'll be fun to see him but in the trailer
you actually only see him in his monster bear form
but just like the beast from beauty and the beast
he's cursed to look like this the big difference
though is that his version of belle is a vampire
all these witcher medallions that you see hanging
up in the great room here of the keep are from
dead witchers who came from the school of the wolf
so this is like a memorial to their dead brother
so to speak we see more action scenes of geralt
and ciri in his new armor pretty much everybody
like i said got a costume upgrade this season
including the nilfgaardians probably the biggest
costume upgrade although geralt's armor does
look pretty sick then obviously the end of the
trailer is dedicated to telling you what happened
to yennefer in the aftermath of the final battle
from season 1 at sadden hill so that's why she's
not around with geralt and ciri at the keep for
a lot of the early season but they do eventually
get reunited jaskier is also back too he shows
up busking for money in the trailer also with
the big costume upgrade himself i don't know
when he's going to be reunited with them during
the season but eventually he will meet up with
them again too then at the end of the trailer you
also hear vesemir speaking for the first time he's
the gruff voice at the end of the trailer talking
to geralt saying what if your princess is more
than you bargained for but even though he doesn't
seem like he's too hot on the idea of ciri right
now he does become quote-unquote uncle vesemir to
ciri kind of like a grandfatherly figure to her
over time who she forms an attachment to then
i'm guessing they didn't reveal the title of the
finale episode 8 just because it winds up being
a spoiler it probably has something to do with a
big villain reveal like vilga ford's ciri the wild
maybe larger cosmic storyline maybe revealing
something big about her father's secret identity
but if there's any big questions or big easter
eggs in the trailer that i didn't talk about
during the video just write them below in the
comments or if you have big questions that you
want me to answer in future witcher videos i've
already done a bunch of witcher season 2 videos so
i'll post links for those down in the description
and the links to my episode videos from season one
while you wait for everything everyone
click here for my full loki episode 5 video
and click here for my brand new
black widow post credit scene video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and toss a coin to your witcher!